juan orlando hernández declaró no ser
culpable de los tres cargos que se le
imputan en eeuu narcotráfico posesión de
armas pesadas y conspiración para la
posesión del armamento la defensa del
expresidente hondureño denunció que le
han dado tratamiento de prisionero de
guerra y anunció que citarán a declarar
a ex presidentes de eeuu como donald
trump y al mismísimo narcotraficante
joaquín el chapo guzmán para defenderlo
porque estuvo estuvieron con él cuando
él ellos querían algo de él ahora que él
necesita su apoyo debe estar aquí para
apoyarlo y de aclarar yo sé que algunas
veces ellos van a tratar de evadir este
las órdenes judiciales pero en este caso
sería bien importante que los jefes de
estado de eeuu vengan a apoyarlo porque
era su aliado principal la fiscalía de
manhattan asegura que hernández recibió
millones de dólares de cárteles de la
droga para financiar sus campañas y que
abusó de su poder para evitar el arresto
de narcotraficantes hernández niega las
acusaciones pero su hermano tony
hernández fue condenado a cadena
perpetua en 2021 por el mismo delito a
las afueras del tribunal hondureños
residente nueva york- piden justicia
pero tarde o temprano va a llegar que le
van a tener que condenar mínimo a una
cadena perpetua por todo el daño que ha
cometido no sólo a honduras sino el daño
que cometió al introducir cocaína a eeuu
este cuando él estuvo el sur en su
gobierno fueron miles de hondureños que
emigraron a causa de sus decisiones y
son injusticias la fiscalía y la defensa
tendrán 60 días para preparar sus casos
la próxima audiencia será el 28 de
septiembre en ella se definirá la fecha
del inicio del juicio que según el juez
federal del distrito kevin castel podría
comenzar el 17 de enero del 2023
hernández fue extraditado a eeuu el
pasado 21 de abril